un 8 mai sous la pluie 8 mai férié
françois mitterrand lance un appel à la
vigilance à la résistance est à l'unité
les malouines toujours les diplomates et
non plus les armes malgré un blocus
renforcé une journée décisive dans ce
cas père général nations unies le
congrès du mrap dans ce journal
un témoignage sur le racisme au
quotidien et puis un accident très grave
aux essais du grand prix automobile de
belgique
le canadien villeneuve entre la vie et
la mort un monsieur bonsoir donc encore
un drame de la course automobile ce soir
ça se passait dans l'ultime séance
d'essais du grand prix de belgique à
zolder
c'est donc le québécois gilles vigneault
qui en a été la victime tout de suite
après l'accident en début d'après midi
on a d'abord annoncé qu'il était
cliniquement mort mais un peu plus tard
un médecin belge a tenté une opération
de la dernière chance intervention
inhabituelle en liaison téléphonique
permanente avec l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes canadiens des problèmes
neurologiques
aux dernières nouvelles le pilote
souffrait de plusieurs blessures au
cerveau il est inconscient et ses
fonctions vitales sont maintenus grâce à
des soins intensifs
prochain bulletin de santé dans deux
heures avec henri bodiguel maintenant
les images de l'accident des images je
le dis tout de suite pour les personnes
sensibles impressionnante
gilles-villeneuve sa ferrari vient de
rattraper jochen mass dont la roue avant
gauche du canadien touche le pneu
arrière droit de l'allemand éjecté de la
voiture gilles ville l'avait projetée
contre les grillages de protection
disposés le long du rail
la ferrari de villeneuve est beaucoup
plus vite que la marge du pilote
allemand meilleur run mme asma
d'ailleurs précisé après l'accident
voyant arriver la ferrari l'a serré sur
sa droite pour lui laisser l'extérieur
seulement c'est justement à droite que
villeneuve a voulu passer lui aussi doux
l'accident
catapulté vers le rail la ferrari fait
d'abord un tonneau puis ce fut levé
reese en retombant gilles villenave est
éjecté de la voiture tandis que son
casque est un mec d'en arracher
et
fran jetés contre les grillages de
protection gilles villeneuve est dans un
état tellement grave que sur place les
sauveteurs ont tenté un massage
cardiaque et un bouche à bouche avant de
l'évacuer vers l'hôpital de louvain oui
des images comme celles ci il nous faut
malheureusement diffusé trop souvent le
dernier accident grave en date étant
celui du français patrick de paille et
les pilotes même accusé pas uniquement
le sort le coéquipier de villeneuve
didier pironi disais tout à l'heure au
nom des pilotes professionnels
nous avons toujours dit que les voitures
étaient devenues trop dangereuses
lorsqu'il n'y avait pas de jupe autour
des véhicules nous serions passés à 180
kilomètres à l'heure dans le virage de
l'accident aujourd'hui c'est du 260 gens
ma mère nous parle de ce problème qui
préoccupe beaucoup les pilotes en ce
moment celui donc des jupes qui entoure
les roues des voitures
ceux qui permettent aux voitures de
formule 1 actuelle de rester coller
autant au sol et de passer de plus en
plus vite en virage en ligne droite est
due aux durcissements des suspensions
mais surtout à l'apparition des jupes à
effet de sol
le système le voici l'air pénètre sur la
voiture pour y être canalisée et les
tuyères sur le côté relie directement la
voiture au sol selon un procédé sachet
est de savoir si ces choses-là ne passe
pas tout le portons
voilà
ça c'est du bois
c'est du bois et du caoutchouc et on
doit rechercher le meilleur bois qui
s'usent le moins possible de façon à les
appuyer le plus possible par terre
les pièces l'air est emmagasinée en vase
clos et forme une canalisation
parfaitement étanche les fuites ont des
conséquences graves car de l'étanchéité
de ce système dépend toute l'efficacité
du plaquage de la voiture au sol mais
aussi et surtout la stabilité de la
voiture
les suites se produisent et nous avons
une tonne de charge et soit laisser les
choses sont étanches les jupes sont
étanches et là nous pouvons avoir deux
tonnes de charge aérodynamique voilà
c'est ce qui fait que la voiture
adhèrent bien nos salons c'est ce que la
voiture a l'air bien aux jeunes se dire
qu'on passe de deux géants virage à 3,5
si nous sommes et ans et là là il est
certain que appartement où tout est ans
on peut gagner deux secondes au tour sur
ce fonctionnement
deux secondes certes mais par ce procédé
en raison des vitesses atteintes
les voitures sont
en véritable avion ou plutôt en bon
et gilles villeneuve en a été victime
cet après midi
oui les pousses de gilles villeneuve
vient d'arriver en provenance de nice au
de chevet de son mari à bruxelles bien
entendu des informations sur l'état de
santé du québécois dès que nous en avons
les yeux n'étaient pas avec nous pour ce
8 mai le premier férié depuis longtemps
pour les deux grandes cérémonies
auxquelles participaient le chef de
l'état une pluie d'automne n'a cessé de
tomber
résultat peu de monde ce matin autour de
la place charles de gaulle pour cette
cérémonie que nous retransmettons ce
matin en direct
en revanche à orléans une assistance
populaire plus fournie pour 1,8 mais pas
comme les autres puisqu'il coïncider
avec les fêtes de jeanne d'arc toujours
très spectaculaire là bas sur place
notre envoyé spécial pierre-alain pour
les orléanais cela fait longtemps que le
8 mai jours fériés et malgré la pluie
battante c'était véritablement l'a fait
que ce 550 troisième anniversaire de la
libération de la ville par jeunes des
fêtes traditionnelles uniforme
d'aujourd'hui et costumes de jadis
laquelle participaient après de gaulle
et valéry giscard d'estaing françois
mitterrand chaleureusement accueilli au
cours de sa promenade dans les rues de
la ville d'emblée le maire udf d'orléans
jacques douffiagues avait contribué à
cet accueil c'est le président de tous
qui nous rend visite et votre présence
ne peut être que le symbole de votre
volonté de réunions des français un
hommage auquel le président mitterrand a
répondu en tirant trois leçons de
l'histoire de jeanne d'arc la vigilance
dans un monde en conflit la france doit
préserver les moyens de son indépendance
la résistance on ne tient bon que par
l'effort et le courage et enfin encore
une fois l'indispensable unité nationale
dans la diversité et le respect des
libertés ou le dirait je mieux qu'ici
et en cette circonstance l'unité
nationale
ce n'est pas l'uniformité c'est le
pluralisme et le choc des idées mais
c'est aussi le sentiment d'appartenir à
une communauté forgée dans l'histoire
apte à épouser son époque prête à la
grande aventure du temps présent où
chacun de nous peut choisir librement sa
manière de vivre
les compagnons de sa vie à la condition
suprême et décisive de savoir vivre
ensemble vigilance résistance unités tel
est le message de jeanne d'arc dans
michel et a pu dire après d'autres avant
d'autres et je pense à péguy mais à sa
manière inimitable et les maths or la
france est la france
touché celui assainir elle-même ce
message mesdames et messieurs restera le
nôtre vive orléans
vive la république vive la france
de la paix on continue à parler en
pointillés ce soit encore dans le
conflit des malouines les français
apparaissent d'ailleurs très préoccupé
puisque 47% d'entre eux pensent que cela
peut déboucher sur une guerre mondiale
41% jugent le contraire est beaucoup
plus massivement encore à la proportion
de trois contre un il estime que la
france ne doit pas soutenir la grande
bretagne 26 % d'entre eux jugeant qu'il
faut l'aider même si cela fait courir à
la france que risquent d'être
directement impliqués dans un conflit
plus générale c'est un sondage commandé
par le journal du dimanche pour son
numéro de demain aujourd'hui donc
toujours le temps des diplomates le
secrétaire général des nations-unies
disais tout à l'heure que la journée
serait décisive
toujours pas l'affrontement depuis la
destruction du sheffield mardi soir mais
de part et d'autre on se mobilise depuis
hier des britanniques on vous le savez
décidé d'interdire aux argentins de
s'éloigner à plus de 12000 de leurs
côtes soit environ 20 km
à londres nous rejoignons bernard rapp
l'élément principal du renforcement
militaire britannique ce sont les 20
chasseurs embarqués arrière comme celui
ci qui sont sur le point de rejoindre
l'escadre au large des fal clan
spécialement modifiées pour être
ravitaillé en vol ses appareils porte à
37 le nombre de arrière désormais 10
paiement
le cil harrier et l'un des avions les
plus sophistiqués en service aujourd'hui
prévu pour l'interception il peut aussi
appuyer les opérations au sol
ainsi il doit non seulement protéger la
flotte contre les attaques aériennes
d'argentine mais sa puissance de feu est
indispensable à tout débarquement
britannique dans l'archipel
les bombardiers vulkan sont un autre
atout pour les britanniques ils peuvent
pilonné non seulement la garnison
argentine sur les falck landes mais
aussi les bases militaires en argentine
même grâce au ravitaillement en vol
le chiffre des navires de combat engagé
dans l'atlantique sud est tenu secret on
estime toutefois à une quarantaine de
bâtiments c'est le porte-aéronefs hermès
qui tient le rôle de navire amiral le
commandant de la flotte le voici
l'amiral woodward c'est de lui que
dépend le succès des opérations
l'escadre est accompagné de navire
ravitailleur qui assure
l'approvisionnement en armes et en
carburant depuis son départ enfin trois
sous marins à propulsion nucléaire qui
doivent couler tout navire argentin qui
pénétrerait dans la zone interdite
la marine marchande apporte aussi sa
contribution 46 bâtiments civils ont été
réquisitionnés comme ici le queen
elizabeth 2 ils ont été transformés en
navires hôpitaux ou un transport de
troupes
si l'ordre est donné ce sont les
fusilliers marins qui débarqueront leur
nombre est secret mais il serait compris
entre trois et cinq mille hommes
parfaitement entraîné comme tous les
militaires britanniques
ce sont des professionnels
aujourd'hui encore de nouvelles unités
sont acheminés vers le théâtre
d'opérations elles doivent rejoindre la
seconde vague déjà en route
la quantité de soldats ainsi engagés
laisse supposer qu'après un débarquement
éventuelles la grande bretagne compte
bien se doter des moyens de défendre
durablement l'archipel reconquis une
tâche difficile à venir à 18 milles
kilomètres de là alors ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que cet
accroissement considérable du potentiel
militaire britannique au large de
l'argentine est déterminant pour la
suite des événements en effet dès leur
arrivée sur le théâtre d'opération c'est
à dire dans les jours qui viennent les
amiraux britanniques auront selon leurs
propres estimations les moyens
nécessaires pour reconquérir par la
force les îles falkland si londres leur
en donne l'ordre
buenos aires a aussitôt accusé les
anglais de vouloir en prenant cette
décision des 12000 étendre virtuellement
la zone de guerre à tout l'atlantique
sud mais plus que jamais
l'argentine paraît que paraît déterminé
à ne céder quoi que ce soit et pour ce
faire le gouvernement façonne et vous
allez voir modèle l'opinion dès
l'enfance et par portage de bruno albouy
cette cérémonie aux accents de la marche
des malouines fait partie du quotidien
des écoliers argentin depuis le 2 avril
dernier
ici dans une école privée de buenos
aires mais la même scène se déroule au
même moment dans tous les établissements
scolaires des enfants au garde à vous
l'impressionnante mobilisation nationale
ne laisse personne à l'écart un mois
déjà que les écoliers vivent au rythme
des communiqués militaires qu'il
collectionne les titres des journaux
dans ses caisses des vivres des lainages
leur contribution au soutien que les
argentins important combattant mais ces
enfants mobiliser rêve aussi de fait si
seulement cette affaire pourrait se
régler en discutant distille cela serait
mieux pour tout le monde pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de morale
c'est la même chose dans cet
amphithéâtre de la faculté des lettres
des étudiants sursitaire se sont portés
volontaires prêts à se faire tuer pour
défendre lisible et pourtant ils sont
plutôt anti militariste hostile par
principe à usage de la force hostile au
soutien armé que buenos aires apporte
aux gouvernements qu'ils combattaient
révolutionnaires d'amérique centrale
mais pour les malouines
tout est différent ce que c'était de la
guerre la vocation du pays s'est passé
lorsque
mais maintenant il est autre chose plus
importante en jeu et c'est ou bien ac le
colonialisme roulante et colonialisme
alors tous bigeard même qu'ils ne soient
pas d'accord avec notre gouvernement
mais qui sont à côté de nos
revendications sont toutes les nations
qui soutient que les colonialismes ne
peut pas exister ici en amérique en rond
xxème siècle sur l'échangé libre wings
ont rejoint à mon avis je crois que
maintenant le gouvernement militaire
après avoir reçu notre aide
l'aide des étudiants des ouvriers des
syndicalistes qui ont été pendant six
ans et dix ont mis en prison sans
liberté à partir de ce moment le
gouvernement devra dire à partir de
demain
vous comptez pour le pays il faut
revenir à la démocratie il faut que vous
ayez de la participation
il faut éclaircir le pôlin de disparus
d'où ce problème inspirent les massacres
qui se sont passés en argentine tout
cela de pas immédiatement devra être
éclairci n'est ce pas ce qu une fois que
tu es un peu trop
au contraire tranquille qu'ils ont
l'appui de l'entreprise et militaires
ils sont d'accord
encore plus fort ils ont encore pour
beaucoup plus d'années de pouvoir les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
dix pays du marché commun étaient réunis
toute la journée à lille belle en
belgique dans les ardennes belges au
principal sujet de discussion le
renouvellement des sanctions économiques
contre l'argentine qui doivent expirer
dans huit jours
cette décision pour l'instant à noter
encore à l'étranger que les iraniens
annoncent avoir repris deux villes aux
irak
voilà pour les nouvelles du monde à
paris le premier ministre a appelé à la
mobilisation des citoyens dans un
message qu'il a adressé au colloque des
clubs de l'unité un autre congrès celui
du mrap le mouvement contre le racisme
et pour l'amitié entre les peuples
à un moment où l'on sent bien de ci de
là quelques poussées de racisme
symbolisée par des tracts où les
attentats comme celui de la mosquée de
roman mais il ya aussi le racisme
ordinaire disons le racisme quotidien
je m'appelle youssef talal je suis
marocain je suis arrivé en france il y a
dix ans et j'ai 27 ans
vous voulez que je vous dise comment je
vis le racisme c'est la première fois
que je les ai vécus
c'est avant de venir ici en france c'est
quand par l'intermédiaire de l'office
nationale des migrations
un patron est venu le chercher
et nos amis dans frontale torse nu et
puis on choisissait les plus jeunes et
les plus costauds pour venir travailler
en france rappelle quand je suis arrivé
beast et un garage une maison à la
campagne
et puis un jour j'ai parlé avec 102
voisins et
la mère d appeler
de façon très violente c'est quand
l'enfant est
c'est arrivé il lui a donné une fessée
alors j'ai senti très très mal j'ai
senti que ça
à migron
mais parler c'était
c'était pour elle travaille
aso va je vois quelqu'un qui mine qui
est différent de l'ostracisme est devenu
très fin
quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
dans la ville tout le tour dans le
quotidien de rapports quotidiens avec
les gens puisque nous parlions
d'attentât il faut savoir que le journal
libanais al watan al arabi apparemment
visé par l'attentât de la rue marbeuf a
décidé de déménager pour accéder au
rocket pressent les voisins demain au
bourget à un rassemblement des partisans
de l'école laïque qui ne manquera pas
d'être interprétée comme une réponse à
ce d'écoles privées qui avaient réussi
il ya quinze jours leur mobilisation en
faveur de l'enseignement libre alors la
veille du 10 mai les organisateurs
entendent fêter le centenaire des lois
laïques instauré par jules ferry une
école laïque qui tente elle aussi de se
renouveler comme en témoigne expérience
de saint fons sur laquelle ont enquêté
lorraine cusin et bernard appelé de
lemieux 40 km de lyon à domaine de 22
hectares acquis par la municipalité de
saint fons pour accueillir toute l'année
des élèves en classe extérieur et les
jours de congés des enfants de banlieue
qui vivent coincé entre les minguettes
de vénissieux et les usines rhône
poulenc la population enfantine de saint
fons comprend 50 % d'immigrés pour ces
jeunes toute une gamme de loisirs
qu'est-ce que tu as comme activité à
saint saëns la danse la la patinoire
le cheval le rugby il croque les chutes
aux efforts paient pour faire son violon
même diversité pour les activités
culturelles et manuelles
chaque enfant possède un passeport
loisirs qui coûte de 10 à 150 francs
selon les familles parents l'enfant
pratique ce qu'il veut
des navettes gratuites se transporte où
il veut richard est élève au centre
socio éducatif de saint fons d'une école
primaire à structurer pédagogie ouvert
et qui brise les carcans scolaire
traditionnel l'école ou vers des parties
de ce principe là qu'il devait y avoir
et qu'il y avait d'autres lieux
éducatifs avant et après ce temps
scolaire à l'école ouverte mais aussi
d'autres lieux éducatifs autour et une
cité de l'or de 17000 habitants permet
effectivement la rencontre entre tous
ces lieux éducatifs
elle peut être le pivot le point de
départ le point d'arriver
aussi de se tromper appelé l'espace
éducatif concertée concertée entre tous
les participants à la formation de
l'enfant
parents enseignants associations à
l'école ouverte on a intégré une maison
de l'enfance
trois animateurs permanents
interviennent dans les activités d'éveil
l'instituteur n'est plus le seul maître
de sa classe l'enfant ne voit plus non
seulement le maître mais ils voient
plusieurs adultes sont susceptibles de
lui amener aussi bien de la
documentation de leur expérience ne leur
technique chose que un seul homme ne
peut pas faire un enfant qui s'expriment
pas le bien français en lecture en maths
peut très bien se rêvait en activités
manuelles et c'est aussi important dans
la vie est la bibliothèque de l'école
des élèves de moins de 12 ans qui la
gère sol ils y viennent à tout moment
développer le sens des responsabilités
des enfants leur autonomie les
accueillir dans toutes leurs différences
sociales et intellectuelles leur
permettre d pas nuire toutes leurs
capacités au sein d'une même école c'est
ainsi que saint fons définit la laïcité
de maintenant si par malheur on tente
d'enfermer un enfant dans une différence
parce que on utilise le plus râler à ce
moment là dans le sens de pluralité des
écoles ont le fortifie dans sa
différence et on fait une société où on
juxtapose les différences et non pas une
société où elle s'interpénètrent
l'enfant qui n'est plus enfermé dans un
temps et un lieu scolaire déterminer une
cité qui reprend et assume ses
responsabilités envers l'enfant espaces
éducatifs concertée la réponse de saint
flour partisans d'écoles différentes
saint fons peut-être le laboratoire de
l'éducation nationale le syndicat
national des journalistes snj dont le
congrès s'est achevé cet après midi à
rouen déçu par la politique
gouvernementale en matière de presse
audiovisuelle et écrite son premier
secrétaire général claude durieux a fait
état d'une forte réserve des
journalistes une manifestation insolite
c'est d'après midi devant la prison de
la santé à paris une centaine de
personnes venaient soutenir un père
menacé de prison pour des caisses de
pension alimentaire jérôme qu'émilie
nous on parlera d'un journal de 23h15 et
puis retour à l'actualité sportive
maintenant toujours pas de nouvelles de
l'état de santé de gilles villeneuve
grièvement blessé je vous le rappelle
lors des essais du grand prix de
belgique en football on appelle
également le sacre de monaco hier à
22h15 au terme d'une folle soirée de
coude à coude avec saint-etienne et
avant une nuit à la brésilienne médigue
est daniel catan déjà quatre fois
vainqueur de la coupe de france monaco a
donc ajouté à son palmarès un quatrième
titre de champion mais cela n'a pas été
sans mal car strasbourg n'était pas venu
en victime résignée et comme à
saint-etienne les choses allaient au
mieux pour les verts virtuellement
champions grâce à l'avalanche qui
s'abattait sur le binôme s la tension
était à son comble au stade louis ii et
puis vint après une heure de jeu ce
corner béni avec un centre de bellonne
et la tête de barbery monaco venait de
signer sa 24e victoire en 38 rencontres
celle qu'il ne fallait surtout pas
laisser échapper
cela valait bien une explosion de joie
et des applaudissements principe sur mes
fesses sérénissime ins rainier iii qui
règne sur quelques 8000 sujet en compte
un de plus depuis hier soir un sujet de
satisfaction
tout à l'heure autre suspense avec la
dernière journée du championnat de
division 2 une lutte à couteaux tirés
entre thonon et toulouse pour le groupe
a est roi et noeux les mines pour le
groupe b et puis de manière plus
anecdotique mais politiquement plus
significative la première journée d'une
équipe palestinienne de football en
france
à l'invitation de la fédération sportive
et gymnique du travail dominique le glou
il a suivi partout dammarie-les-lys
c'est le centre de vacances d'un comité
d'entreprise qui héberge depuis quelques
jours la sélection des joueurs
palestiniens
ces jeunes sportifs sont protégés par 25
crs une protection discrète 24 joueurs
choisis parmi quinze mille footballeur
disséminés dans les différents pays
arabes
il a fallu attendre 1971 pour que l'ol
perd et organise un conseil supérieur de
la jeunesse et des sports pour la
première fois ses joueurs exilés dont
les différents fonds syriens ou libanais
sont en europe et sortent des pays
arabes
chants révolutionnaires mais aussi
écouter bien été plus surprenant
berceuse le calme
ce nombre à leur bonheur aucun des
joueurs sélectionnés net originaires des
territoires occupés par israël et au
niveau individuel les jeunes en
territoires occupés pratiquer le sport
mais à cause de la répression il leur
est impossible de s'organiser sur le
plan sportif à la pratique on doit se
fonder des clubs palestinien a droit
art
les palestiniens s'organise là où ils
sont réfugiés comme ils le peuvent ils
ont par exemple créé 40 clubs au liban
dont 23 à beyrouth dans des conditions
très difficiles
le sport est devenu pour eux un moyen de
reconnaissance un moyen pour défendre la
cause palestinienne
oui je me considère comme un militant de
la cause palestinienne mais aussi comme
un militant sportif
on dit souvent en europe on entend
souvent dire que derrière chaque
palestinien ni un combattant
voire même un terroriste non nous sommes
comme tous les autres peuples nous
luttons pour notre droit au retour nous
ne sommes pas des terroristes nous
sommes des révolutionnaires civilisé on
peut rajouter que ce sont aussi de bons
footballeurs certes pas encore au niveau
des grands du football d'aujourd'hui
mais la naissance et le développement du
football palestinien est tellement
récent que ce serait un miracle
en attendant voici un aperçu de leur
talent prometteur croyez-moi nous faire
bien frapper dans le ballon
talents de footballeur est donc un peu
plus curieusement de chanteurs fin du
tour de corse en tête depuis le début de
l'épreuve jean ragnotti que voici et
jean marc andrieu sur renault 5 turbo
ont remporté ce soir la 26e édition du
tour de corse devant jean claude andruet
et biches sur ferrari c'est la première
victoire de jean ragnotti en corse
première victoire que le pilote français
a bien exploité durant toute la durée de
l'épreuve d'autant qu'à un mauvais et
mauvais équipement
des matchs
a lourdement pénalisé retrouvé hier en
fin de journée
voilà on va parler car c'est maintenant
d'abord le carnet du jour ça se passait
à evry fallait jouer le 14 le 11 et le
dise pour avoir dans l'ordre quelque
chose comme 26 mille francs et dans un
ordre différent presque 4000 francs le
tout donc pour la mise initiale de
quatre de cinq francs demain de masse et
selon jan chan demain oui et puis à
quelque chose près le tiercé de demain
ressemble à celui du 18 avril puisqu'il
réunit en majorité les mêmes partant et
ce prix des gravilliers le tiercé de
demain donc je au chant risque fort
d'être une belle revanche pour certains
des concurrents qui se rencontrent
encore une fois dans la même course
toutefois ces caisses concurrents sont
bien difficiles à départager car leurs
champs sont équilibrés soit parce qu'ils
aiment le terrain lourd soit parce qu'il
porte un poids favorable ou encore parce
qu'ils ont tiré un bon numéro à la corde
mais ce n'est malheureusement pas le cas
de présentant qui déjà lors de récents
tirs s'est avaient été débattus par un
mauvais numéro de départ cette fois
encore il joue de malchance
pareil on a tiré le 14 ans ont une fois
sur quinze partants c'est vraiment là la
chance il ya rien à faire quand on fait
qu'on a allongé numéro qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est pas ça se passe bien
enfin signalons que les autres vous
laisse passer devant au départ oui
fallait que je parte bien je prenais pas
qu'ici remporté le pro vite il faut
tâcher 4 5e position mais pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'il assortit culié pourquoi
il faut absolument qu'ils soient dans
les trois premiers cécile est trop loin
il revient pas celle du courage ce mois
il faut une grosse formation s'ils
avaient la chance que la de la course se
déroule au mieux pour lui et ce qu'il
peut gagner se tenir fin avril à une
chose toute façon il a une chance malgré
un numéro 14 à cordes
oui je peux prendre une place ça se
passe bien
bien personnellement j'y crois puisque
dans la sélection que je vous propose
présentant sans tête
je lui oppose santa nicosia qui porte un
coiffeur 45 kilos et demi ensuite majeur
satimo le numéro 2 windjet qui a une
revanche à prendre sa dernière course
justement du pineau le numéro 11
alone in terris ce 13 movilla le sexe et
pois chiches numéro 10 fois l'annoncé
vient leur numéro 9 14 de cette housse
13 5 et 10 voilà après les pronostics et
les prévisions de la météorologie
nationale lui ai expliqué imaginer
inventer par notre ami alain juppé alain
gillot-pétré et d'écouté c'est assez
stable pour demain il y aura du soleil à
l'ouest et des nuages à l'aise comme je
vous l'avais dit hier d'ailleurs soit
dit en passant bravo à la météo
nationale
alors pour demain donc sur une petite
moitié est du pays beaucoup de nuages de
l'alsace-lorraine roussillon elle
accorde beaucoup de nuages avec des
pluies très abondantes et continue et
des rafales de vent de nord-est en
méditerranée tandis que sur une grande
moitié ouest du pays
des brumes le matin que je retire et
l'après midi vous le voyez davantage
d'éclaircies qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr en
tout cas des éclaircies de plus en plus
belle par l'ouest les températures pour
demain alors continue qu'elle n'a plus à
l'est
sam a baissé à l'esm et contenus qui
aura un peu de soleil à l'ouest ça va
monter à l'ouest c'est aussi simple que
ça en avait bien besoin 14 pour paris
demain alors qu'aujourd'hui à 16 heures
il faisait seulement 8 degrés ce qui est
10 degrés en dessous des normes
saisonnières
c'est vous dire demain dimanche 9 mai
deux minutes de sommeil supplémentaires
levé 6h20 coucher 21h04 c'est la fête de
sainte jeanne d'arc est une des
patronnes de la france bien sûr ceci
l'aca pas compte que moins connu c'est
quand même assez bien 23h15 hervé claude
de nous donnera les toutes dernières
informations il nous donnera je pense
des nouvelles de l'état de santé du
québécois gilles villeneuve accidenté
tout à l'heure lors de la dernière
séance d'essais du grand prix automobile
de belgique
voilà merci de nous avoir écoutés demain
à 12h40 50e 2010 et philippe labro et a
maintenant j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver